hi everyone thanks for coming to
much-talked-about
I know everyone is saying happen maybe
it's because I'm like in the Installer
this is super bright all right thanks
everyone for coming to my talk this
lights are uploaded on that URL if you
want to follow along but you can also
check them out afterwards I want to kick
things off with a kind of important
message um and that's that you're all
wasting your time learning frameworks
because we got web api's and so we have
web components on other things and
there's really no need for any kind of
frameworks but before I'm getting kicked
off stage I know this statement is not
100% true and the story is much more
complex but I think I got everyone's
attention now and I got an excuse to use
the confetti animation in keynote so
that's great so I'm Dominic I work as a
developer evangelist at Twilio and if
you don't know about Twilio we're a
cloud communications platform so we have
a bunch of different API that allow you
to do things like sending or receiving
SMS doing phone calls video and a bunch
of other things um and I'm also reactive
all power left building with react um
it's a great great framework for a lot
of the things that I built as demo apps
I'm also an angular developer I
developed with angular for quite a while
um I love using web components because I
think there's like a good use case for
them I build things with for the front
end and the back end and I love playing
around with hardware as well so I'm a
hardware developer as well but if people
asked I I describe myself as a
JavaScript developer because all of the
things that I talked about I see much
more frameworks and libraries as tools
rather than anything else and tools are
here to solve problems and these
problems might change over time you know
based on my team based on the project
based on the time that like overall that
I have for a project um and that gets me
back to the statement of you're wasting
your time learning frameworks because
while I don't believe it I think it was
a good generalizer to get your attention
and we probably all heard or said
something like this
which is that you're wasting your time
learning X because Y exists already or
because y is faster for some reason or Y
is better just generally because I saw
some benchmarks saying that or it's just
because Y is more popular and I see it
more often on my Twitter feed and so I
wanted to go back and talk about why we
have framers in the first place and that
is to solve problems as I said and any
framework or tool is ultimately there to
solve a specific problem and if you
don't believe me I wanted to go back in
history and kind of talk about a couple
of things from the his from the web
development history and the tools how
they've developed over time and note
that I'll be talking about about a
couple of things but those are
definitely not all of them and like
there's more things that they've evolved
over time but those are some things I
personally interacted with so I felt
most connected to those and so I wanna
start off with jQuery I think we've all
interacted at one point with jQuery
regardless of how long you've been doing
web development and I wanted to figure
out like why does jQuery exist in the
first place
oh it's actually pretty easy to figure
out because if we go to the website
there's literally a section that it's
called what is jQuery and it talks about
that Jaykar isn't easy to use API that
works across a multitude of browsers um
and that might seem normal these days
where like we require everything to just
work in every browser but in 20 2006
when j.crew was released we're in the
middle of the browser Wars Firefox 2 was
just released Internet Explorer 7 was
just a leased and released and according
to Wired it was not as standards
compliant as people had hoped for
um chrome was not on the market there
were opera and Safari and a couple of
others like Camino flock and browser
were served the other ones that were on
the radar so jquery's goal was really to
provide a unified access to the dom and
web requests and if you're not sure why
that seemed to be a problem this is how
you had to attach an event in 2006 you
had to check if it's if an event
listener actually exists because that
didn't exist in
Internet Explorer but hey they had
attached event um so you could use that
instead and so jQuery gave you like a
unified way of using the on of method to
actually access or set an event handler
uh and similarly you know like if you
wanted to do a web request you have to
check if you're in ie6 and get an
ActiveX object um to do an HTTP request
and then you had to write all this
boilerplate and Ajax just streamline
that process for you and so with better
access to the dom and we ended up
building more applications that are UI
heavy from a javascript perspective and
so we found the need for having more
complex user controls like date pickers
for example and so projects like jquery
UI came around to have an ability to
teach you to share and build reusable
components like date pickers accordions
and other things so you can build them
into application so we all jumped on
that and kind of started building more
complex user interfaces for the browser
and so our need for tools to structure
more complex applications grew and so we
got tools like backbone that literally
focused on giving your application
structure to introduce models and views
and things like that but at the same
time some people didn't feel really
comfortable with the fact that basically
all of our document structure moved into
javascript and so some people wanted to
go back to a more declarative way of
describing you eyes rather than
imperative through javascript which
caused the creation of frameworks like
angular JS which focuses on extending
the HTML vocabulary to allow creating
dynamic views in the declarative way
rather than having to write a bunch of
JavaScript statements and as our code
bases grew we needed to have ways to
handle that concatenating javascript
files was not the only like or the the
best use case anymore and so in so we
came up with module syntax like require
jazz or bundlers you know that like came
like browserify and web pack later etc
and as people kept on developing those
solutions and platforms developed our
problems kept on changing and new
frameworks and tools showed up so by now
there we got flooded with different
frameworks that could handle different
use cases and so I think the important
thing to keep in mind here is that all
of these tools were created because
people had problems and wanted to find a
way to solve these problems they got
together with others and build these
solutions but building a framework is
very much more of a life cycle so while
some you know gained mainstream
popularity others often kind of stay as
like niche solutions and additionally to
that we often have some that you know
just disappear over time for various
reasons for example jQuery kind of went
away out out of the spotlight because we
moved into standards that solved exactly
these problems so we have query selector
and add eventlistener
now to solve a lot of the common calf
Dom accessing problems and we have tools
like fetch that don't require us to use
Ajax or something anymore to have a kind
of cross-platform thing but while
standards might solve a problem I also
have to disappoint you because if your
favorite solution gets standardized it
does not necessarily mean it gets
standardized the same way because
standardization is hard and to take and
it has to take into consideration a lot
of different aspects because it has to
solve the problem for everyone and not
just a share of folks and the best way
to explain how standards are being
developed these days is with the
extensible web manifesto if you haven't
heard of the extensible web manifesto
it's a manifesto that was written by a
bunch of folks are involved with
standardizing browser features to kind
of guide what kind of things should be
standardized in the browser and it
focuses on four key concepts the first
one is that it focuses on adding new low
level low level capabilities to build to
build the web platform that are secure
and efficient so what that means is like
if we look at things like WebGL for
example or on features like
now I have a hanger Oh Oh web assembly
if you if you look at web assembly or
WebGL those are very low-level things
that we can build tools on top like a
frame or three Jas to use them but it's
also that they should explain existing
features so that's a good example for
things like the Houdini API or the web
web components back because they explain
how the browser already handled CSS or
introduces new components and so it just
exposes those to the outside and then
the other two are key in my opinion for
us to help browser standardize things
the first one is to create a constant
virtuous cycle of feedback so this is
very important because it shows sort of
in some standards like the web
components spec why it took so long
because developers were not willing to
have on board and try the new things and
it's that weighted off and so the
browser vendors didn't get any feedback
on standardizing this and the other
thing is that they're focusing on
prioritizing efforts based on those
recommendations that they're getting and
D prioritizing others which again have
falls back into the same thing if we
want to want something to come and we
want to have feet we want to have an
impact we need to give feedback we need
to try these things as soon as there's
polyfills and things like that but if
you want to learn more about the CAF
standardization process you want to
check out the talk from Monica Niculescu
about how the web sausage gets made from
2017 it's focusing especially on server
web components evolved over time but
it's overall a great talk to learn more
about the extensible web manifesto the
other thing is that like if something
gets standardized it might not actually
necessarily look the same way so we have
we already saw the example of Ajax
turning into like the fetch command I
just promise based so that it's better
integrates with the rest of the
ecosystem and there's more future-proof
the other example is required jazz and
common jazz were around for quite a
while until we got yes modules and it
looks significantly different but it
took kind of the asynchronous aspect of
required jazz and a couple of other
concepts of like common jazz to merge
them into something that made sense for
the browser
and ultimately for the ecosystem one
common one that I hear about at least on
Twitter a lot these days is about the
conversation about standardizing JSX and
at least in my personal opinion JSX for
example makes this fairly hard because
by nature JSX is rendering independent
we set the renderer to during the
compile time to JavaScript and it just
translate translates that to a bunch of
function calls that we can use and so we
actually already have something that
allows you to do that where it's a bunch
of where you define a function and then
that returns somehow it put and we can
use it in an easy way with an arbitrary
syntax and that's tag templates so we
can create any sort of function that
produce that takes care of the input
that we put in allows us to interpolate
values and then create any output we
want be it a new string or anything else
and so Jason Miller the creator of
pre-act actually took that as an example
and build HTM which allows you to use
react pre actor anything else's JSX base
without having to compile by using tag
templates and yes the tooling is not as
great right now around this as like JSX
might be around typescript and stuff
like that but that's because we're not
heavily invested in this yet and so
again unless we use things things are
not being built because the problem
doesn't become big enough for people to
solve it but even if things don't get
standardized sometimes projects just
drastically change or come to an end
so angularjs is a great example with
react and other things coming around
after 2010 the angular team took took
some time and took a step back and
looked at sort of what the current
ecosystem is and wanted to create a new
thing that solved their problems in a
way that they thought it made sense and
so angular 2 was a drastic rewrite and
though of the way you would create
applications and frankly that meant that
some people moved off to react or view
or other things because for them
ultimately their problems align better
with what reactant view we're trying to
solve
and so often I see the statement or hear
it that angular is dead but angular is
very much not that the community just
doesn't overlap much with like the
community that writes things like react
um but in fact I looked there's for
example 21 angular specific conferences
in 2019 versus I think I found 22 react
conferences and also additionally to
that like we tend to be in serve our
JavaScript bubble of people who are
full-time JavaScript developers oh but
there's lots of other people who write
javascript on a regular basis without
identifying themselves as we as
JavaScript developers via people who
write dotnet or Java or any other
language
um the other part of the kind of
framework life cycle I want to talk
about just how frameworks inspire each
other and learn from each other um I
think one good example is the origin of
view so view was created by Avenue at
the time he was working at Google but or
had just left Google I think and he was
inspired by angularjs because he had to
build a lot of things with angularjs but
he wanted to solve some of his own
problems and so to quote him I wanted to
I wondered something that captured the
declarative nature of Angela's data
binding but with a simpler and more
approachable API that's how view started
and so here we can see one of those
classic examples is actually written
down of how they inspired each other but
this is constantly happening in the
ecosystem another example is toolkits
I think we've all used something like a
view CLI angular CLI pre-act CLI there's
lots of different sea allies around
these days but one of my favorite parts
of inspiration here is I want to talk
about the angular CLR I'm more
specifically about the ember CLI because
until last year there were plenty of
references in the angular CLI source
code about ember CLI and that's because
the angular CLI started off with
literally having the ember CLI as a
dependency and so they took kind of
inspiration one step further by relying
on that and then building on top of that
but sometimes the inspiration also comes
from the community so if you didn't hear
about the term ahead of time compiling
that's basically a technique that
frameworks like angular or spelt used to
move during like a compiling step remove
unnecessary code and improve the startup
time and bundle size by removing parts
of the library that are unnecessary and
so inspired by that technique from
spelled tobias from the web pack team
actually build a proof of concept that
did the same thing with react and called
it react where it actually removes the
video implementation and a bunch of
other things from react and instead
replaces that with direct rendering
instructions for the Dom which makes at
least some applications way smaller but
this also gets me to the fact that like
not everything works for every use case
because he points out in his repository
that this is largely useful for things
where your application has less
components than the size of the react
react source code or if you're trying to
do things like building web components
where you don't want to ship the
entirety of react with every web
component so if you want to build a date
picker but you want to use react and
then distribute it to everyone else you
can do that without having to distribute
that also a fair warning the raw acting
is very much a proof of concept but I
hope that react does to tape picking
that up over time but that gets me to
the fact that people just have different
requirements and ultimately different
backgrounds and different challenges
they are trying to solve and we tend to
forget about that a Java developer for
example might feel more comfortable with
the fact that how dependency injection
works in angular or a.net developer
might feel more comfortable with an
opinionated framework that tells them
how to do how to solve certain problems
because that's what they're used to in
an enterprise developer might have a
better chance to use a framework that is
batteries included rather than having to
go through approval for every every
single library that solves a small
challenge instead but as much as
frameworks are about solving problems
they're also about hype in fact they're
very much about hype to quote marks tybo
making a popular open-source project is
10% idea 15% code and 75% community
building and marketing and I think
that's very true by the way if you don't
know much story he created style
components among other things so he
knows what he is talking about there
and I think two good examples are aralia
and spelled Aurelia was created in 2015
by Rob Eisenberg who had left the
angular team because he had some
disagreement around the design decisions
that the angular team was doing and so
he created his own framework and it's
actually a really good framework there's
being used it's just not as widely known
as angular for example or react and the
other one has spelled and spelled is a
framework that has a lot of great
concepts like the ahead of time
compiling and others and it might
actually be useful for your own project
but the chances are when you evaluate it
another framework you might have just
not heard about it and therefore it
didn't even take it into consideration
so hyper really is what makes a
framework but less hype doesn't mean
that it's killing the framework and that
gets me to one of I think like the one
thing I want you to take away from this
talk and that's let's not call
frameworks dead because in JavaScript
nothing really ever dies 70% of the top
million websites still use jQuery and
things like angular and amber and others
have vibrant communities and by us
talking about like a technology being
dead I feel like it's very disrespectful
for the people who both still maintain
these things but also the people who
have to work with them on a regular
basis but also sometimes yes some
frameworks go on maintained but that
still doesn't mean that they're dead
because people don't have the luxury of
being able to change overnight to a new
framework because the command so as long
as those tools still solve problems for
people the community likely is gonna
stick around it might shrink in size but
that still doesn't mean that it's dead
and so I like the comparison of how
frameworks and libraries are like
hammers there's like an unlimited amount
of them and they have different sizes
different manufacturers and different
specializations but please don't tell
someone to buy a new hammer because if
they already have one and it solves
their problem because they only have to
put a nail into a wall like once a month
or once a year don't tell them they need
to drop their hammer because it's not
efficient and they need to
I knew carpenter hammer it's not their
use case because they don't need it that
often so let's stop kind of making
people feel bad about that let's stop
telling people they are wasting their
time because ultimately if they're happy
with their solution oh they will
they're totally fine to keep using it so
let's not make them feel bad all right
to wrap things up I want to update and
ask from Dan Abramov from 2016 and I
want to update it to take some time and
build a side project or something with a
framework or a tool that you're not
familiar with and approach it with an
open mind so that you can use the tools
and the frameworks that they build
around it the philosophies of how they
structure their their applications and
learn from that and then don't look down
on others and try to convince them to
change to your favorite tools instead
talk to each other talk about why they
chose it and why you chose your solution
what they like and dislike about about
it share your own experiences and help
each other and learn from each other
because if frameworks can learn from
each other and evolve then you can - all
right if you want to check out the
slides they're on this URL and I'll
tweet about them afterwards as well and
with that I would like to say thank you
and if you have any questions I'll be
around so feel free to talk to me
afterwards or hit me up on Twitter or by
email thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]